can pay our rent and put food on the
table and do everything that you know I
would be working to provide half of
absolutely fine I can do without the
maid I can do without you know all of
that let me just focus on our home you
bring the money in and I'll make our
home a home and that way I will be more
happier because to be honest you know I
am a working woman and I've got a child
it's stressful you know that morning
rush to get that little four-year-old
ready and she don't understand why I'm
rushing and she's you know money money
and I've got a Russia get her in the car
drop her off I've done a whole shift
before I've gone to work and then I've
got to deal with people that I work with
and then you know hard stop five o'clock
I need to stop this meeting I need to
rush out to you know to my colleagues
you know I might look like you know I
don't put any meetings in our diary
after five o'clock because you know
she's a single mom and there's that
stigma that you've got to deal with so
the short answer yeah okay
um I think I could I think
in reality that I would have to
I don't think it would be easy to
but I would work at it because I don't
like especially with the way it is to
live now I would not leave an
opportunity to make more money
um because my man doesn't
but I will always strive to respect him
um and leave him to do the providing so
essentially if I bought more money into
the house that's just more spending
money in my opinion I would allow him
like I would leave him to his role
basically yeah let me ask you this what
is it like being a stay-at-home mom
wow
do you know what it's it's fine it's
good because
to me I like raising my children is my
priority and looking after my home is my
priority everything else is extra
but as long as I can give myself the
space to do the extra I'm I'm happier
that way if my whole life was just at
home with the kids and maintaining my
house I don't know how happy I would be
only because I had a lifestyle before
getting married that I had I liked and
so I think here I have the best of both
worlds but I think and actually so I'm
confused are you not a stay-at-home mom
I am a stay-at-home mom but I I do bits
on the side so okay I yeah so um I'm a
stepmom coach yeah but my house doesn't
depend on the money I make all the money
I make it's fun so you work from home
yes I'm I'm yeah I'm always at home yeah
I come out to to do a speaking gig or
something like that yeah okay so yeah I
would strive to respect but he will
always be the provider and I'm okay with
that whatever that was like okay and
just like you said also to her you know
how you were saying um you can have a
man on like a normal wage and still be a
stay-at-home mom he doesn't have to be
earning thousands that is very true like
I essentially what we say in our
cultures cut your cult according to your
size whatever my husband makes our life
I will maintain our life according to
what he makes and as long as our
Necessities are are met there's really
there shouldn't be a complaint
I like you yeah thank you I like you too
um okay so could you respect a man that
you make more than
yes
the answer is yes however I want to see
him
being ambitious he has to have a plan he
has to be someone that gets up no money
no that's not the that's not the guy
you're dating no
it's like that's like the women trying
to change men no he's he's making let's
say what's whatever the average salary
is here 35 000 pounds a year
he will always be making thirty five
thousand dollars a year okay this isn't
build a man but what kind of person is
he the kind of guy that wakes up and
plays video games and just he's the kind
that he's he goes to work okay and makes
35 000 a year and then he comes home
sometimes he plays video games sometimes
he doesn't the same way you know it's
like they we can complain about the
video games but how many girls are on
social media for hours
we're just as bad no you know what
you're right
I think I could because I've been in
that situation and I've been very happy
with
that okay why aren't you with him he's
in Australia oh oh no so this was recent
yeah okay I don't know what he makes
it's none of my business but I know he's
not like the richest guy in the world
but he's lovely and he actually made me
feel safe in every way so how do you
know that you earn more than him I don't
but if I did I'd be okay with it because
he was that wonderful
okay okay so yeah sounds like you need
to go back to Australia finish your
healing well uh that was the plan not
for him though but I would like to see
him again 100 oh do you think you're
healed enough though
um wait I'm confused so when was the
okay so it wasn't the the old guy eight
months ago
yeah that was in June okay and then when
did the the Australia guy come in
literally this month oh oh and he left
to Australia no I was in Australia she
went away to Australia for six weeks so
this is why when men sleep clear with
everything the guy say so this is why
when guys say like you're healing they
just think you I mean they don't have
nothing yeah you're just sleeping with
other dudes
um no because it wasn't quite like that
it took me a long time to even go on a
date with someone like it wasn't until I
went to Australia I considered that I
was just completely
right but you told me you were healing
earlier in Australia yeah and now you're
telling me you met the guy in Australia
it's no it's no hate to you I'm just no
it's fine I'm just observing he's a
Healer and that if I'm honest because I
said that to him because he was going
through his own thing which I won't
discuss on here that's his business and
I was going through mine
and I said to him for whatever reason I
walked into your life and you walked
into mine because it was an accident you
know I was walking down the street she
goes oh you met him on the street what
happened was I just come back from the
gym I was in a bad mood I smell I was
covered in sweat I was spotty I was like
you know on my period so I was like
bloated and I did not look appealing at
all and this stunning man walks towards
me and when I fancy someone I get shy
and I just looked down
and he starts talking to me and I'm just
like in my head I'm like why today why
today
and then he's like you should smile you
know it looks good on you and then we
were just talking
and um
I felt really good
around this person he made me feel safe
there's something about his energy that
just made me feel really good
and you were able to trust him
it was more
I know that sounds wild because even I
look back and I think how did I do that
to an extent yeah because I said to him
what are you doing later let's go out
it was me that initiated it and then
when he went in to kiss me he said he
asked my permission he's this is after
the date he said can I kiss you you know
he was asking my permission he was
respectful of my boundaries he was you
know
but you know how you said that you were
going through your stuff and he was
going through his stuff you said that
about your ex the one who was obviously
dealing with anorexia you said
um he his traumas and neural traumas
like were able to go together and now
you're saying basically as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible